is a Super Bowl champion nine-time Pro
Bowl or a Defensive Player of the Year
who spent 12 seasons in the NFL many of
them with the Dallas Cowboys but he won
his championship with the Denver Broncos
on behalf of Snickers good buddy
DeMarcus Ware here on the Rich Eisen
show has promised how are you DeMarcus
hey what is up man long time no hear
from it's too long I'm glad that you're
here on the program let's start right
into it let's dive in with both feet
what is it like negotiating with Jerry
Jones you know the thing is it's like a
two-step process first he's gonna talk
to your agent and get noticed the waters
a little bit on the numbers once you
finalize the numbers let's say if
there's five million dollars if it needs
to be there's leftover maybe and
guarantee or you know mine is going to
be cut off the top and then you're going
to sit down with them there's far not
gonna be any agents around and you're
gonna be sitting at his desk the lights
are dim with the candle and it's gonna
be one of those things where you're like
holy cow like what type of meeting is
this going to be and he's not gonna
smile anymore he's gonna actually want
to ask you or actually tell you the
contract constituencies let's say what
Zeek when I saw him getting off that
plane on my own once he talks to Jerry
it's gonna be over I and Jerry will
probably look at him in his eyes with a
crazy stare and say six years ninety
million dollars he's probably not gonna
say any type of guarantee and he's and
he's gonna say for this can you empty
the bucket for the Dallas Cowboys and if
you say yes she's not worried about
anything else because he knows that you
know you're gonna give it your all and I
think that's what he did when he went in
there and that's why he got the
contractor here don't know so you think
he did when he got off the plane go and
have a face-to-face with Jerry for sure
for sure for sure no doubt about it no
doubt about it so I have some other
questions is the candles scented
DeMarcus is it a scented candle is not
scented but it does have a Dallas
Cowboys symbol on
before the candle actually melts down
and then shoots the star you better have
your answer how many times did you do
this is it a to death how many times did
you resign without twelve why was it the
same thing each time and he has a suit
on which is very intimidating because
you like it's like a press conference so
what I mean is like a nice suit to it
boots off and did you go into the saying
the second time all right I know what
happened the first time
I am NOT gonna do X Y & Z this time did
you have that mentality the second time
I went in there it was a totally
different story and I walked in there
with Jerry Jones and he says excitons
anything I listen to I said I'm not
gonna say a word what does Jerry had to
say he had a suit on same atmosphere and
he says DeMarcus you get into all your
also Dallas Cowboys but I want to let
you know that I can't pay you this 16
million dollars that I owe you I can't
and I'm gonna release you and let you
test the market if there's something
that's out there that maybe I can
Kontest to but you've given it your all
for me and I'm gonna give you an
opportunity to go out here and see just
where you are in the market place and lo
and behold ever give me a big contract
and he couldn't claim you that contract
and he said you know what the markers
you know I brought you in here and you
get your name in the stone for the
Dallas Cowboys in the star and when you
retire will you come back and retire as
a Dallas Cowboy and I'm looking at him
in my face in his face and I said yes
because I started my career here and
that's where I want to finish my career
and she's okay and he gets up and all of
a sudden you know his secretary comes in
they're like where's he going
and he goes to have the press conference
and talk to everyone about releasing it
but I was like that the real Jerry Jones
that I know that's why I have so much
respect
- because she sits you down and he's
honest with you saying that either imma
imma be R to pay you I'm not gonna be
the pay Wow
the Marcus we're here on the Rich Eisen
show and so Zeke signing do you think
that puts the Cowboys over the top
that's it
well I think I think that puts him over
the top and puts them back in the
contender seat because now they got a
guy that can go in and move the chains
take some pressure off the deck but dad
can now be back and she's made it to the
postseason I feel like not even close it
I think about how younger team is and
all this firepower from Jaylon Smith
bender as Sharlee you got you know dad
kumari Cooper just to name a few you got
Frederick back you got little collars
that just sigh you got time you name it
how many what team in the league has
this type of young fire politic and now
go and do it now it's like you got the
NFC East right look at right in front of
you the first day good John
next game Washington Redskins then after
that it's a lot of NFC team that you're
gonna have the plane how will you play
the beginning of this season there's
gonna dictate what your post seasons all
the way do you think Jerry's had the
candle what conversation with Jack yet
not yet oh you know you you will know
when that candle light I would say
candle light contract dinner is gonna be
had with that because something's going
to sign when you start saying that Jerry
offered this you know that something's
happening and that candle light contract
there is going to happen I don't know
would you have that wood deck DeMarcus
though I mean like here we are we're on
the eve of the Giants Cowboys opener
that Zeke is gonna be starting and you
know do you start talking dollars and
cents and stare at your quarterback and
ask you know you're gonna fill up the
bucket for the Cowboys when you're you
got to play football I mean this is the
thing I think that you know I would be a
little quiet about it if I was in
Jerry's position because that already
know that he wants to play for the
Dallas Cowboys and for me it's like okay
well you just gave me
see you gave me a mari you gave every
single thing that I need to now prove to
you why I need to get this big contract
and for me are they clear I won't say a
word I'll actually play been here and
I'll let the ante go up because you give
me every single thing to prove Who I am
now you just got to go out there and do
it without being distracted about money
about where I need to be because these
contractors are giving out right now huh
you think about golf
100 million are you kidding me that's
why I would want and I started to show
this way DeMarcus Ware that if I owned a
team I'd say sign everybody early so I
would find them early as I could
yeah but again you don't want the
distractions either I will try to sign
like a Dex
earlier before God so then you won't
have to think about that hundreds do you
think do you think jack is worth that
money though DeMarcus Ware do you think
you have no choice but to pay him I
wanted to say he's working money have no
choice but to pay him because what he's
done he has proved himself that he can't
be that guy and I think it okay if you
trade them not you look at the
first-round draft pick you know that
first-round draft picks can be bucks you
don't know what you want to get so as
being conservative as Jerry Jones would
be I would go with what I know and the
team that I'm putting put together
because it's a team sport
everybody got to put in their eye they
say there's no I in team but you gotta
you know you gotta do what you have to
do so I think that you pay them I think
that you can't because there's nothing
else out there but also he's also losing
himself who do you think is your
Defensive Player of the Year candidate
here player year I would say I would say
Khalil Mack this year why because
because because not only is he gonna be
a guy that's gonna be cheat on but I
feel like he feel like he was snubbed
from what I know feel like he was snow
from last year I'm being a defensive guy
and now he's gonna bring a lot more
tenacity to the game and he's the only
guy that I know that wherever you put
him it in
side buyer and Donnell they can really
get the job done no matter where you put
that sucker he is amazing
when it comes to stripping sacks making
touchdowns and then getting over 15
sacks a year well I'm concerned about
the Bears defense on the whole I know
they're very talented because Vic Fangio
is not the coordinator there anymore no
Chuck Connors very talented and what's
what's Fangio going to unlock for the
Broncos defense do you think you know
barn has always played on the left-hand
side and he's able to be keyed on very
easy and you can see that they brought a
couple guys and a lot of young guys and
mature too they can now take a lot of
pressure on football and with big Fangio
you can see how he did with Khalil Mack
where they moved him around he plays a
little bit of inside back he plays
outside back he plays right left because
now you can go and key on a lot of the
weak links it's not about how many
sections it's about making those big
plays and if you put your key players in
position to make plays that's what you
want and I've seen big Fangio do that
with you know the Chicago Bears and
talking with Vaughn like how excited he
is like man I feel so good and about you
know not having to drop as much well I'm
actually blitzing from left and right
there's so much that we're actually
doing I've never done before I'm like
man this that's a good thing here and so
that makes me feel good especially with
chip coming on strong like he is it
haven't already starting the season off
like from the preseason I think they're
gonna be really good defense what are
you doing with Snickers this year
DeMarcus you're gonna reward the NFL's
hungriest players and fans what does
that mean yes man so the hungriest
players and fans meaning that from on
the field performance meaning the
players to off the field charity work
that they do they have this blinged out
chain by a guy named Ben baller awesome
jeweler I've been earlier in your
hometown out there but it's sort of
given to each player every single week
I'm the initiator of it anymore I'd say
okay you perform like you should have
performed on and off the field and give
back to them but then there
Claire's responsibility to go give it to
another player so then like the fans can
get involved you know we got to have 12
men involved so they can go and follow
this chain by doing hashtag Snickers
chain it's almost like the new Flat
Stanley I like it's going to travel with
a story right but then the story ends up
with the value of this chain of the
finalists of this person who wins it
getting that money donated to the
charity of their choice so that's why I
really enjoy doing things like this
because not only other player good on
the field but they also be committed off
the field with opportunity like this and
they can go to any social media platform
their sneakers on Twitter you know
Instagram any social media and just
snickering and get involved and win win
our rewards as well yeah go to at
Snickers on social media for the chance
to win rewards and see which player
receives the chain each week and then at
the end the $60,000 chain is going to be
awarded to the charity of the choice of
the league's hungriest player has voted
you know what DeMarcus I'm always hungry
and they always do have a Snickers on
the set an NFL game day morning because
they think whenever I in a very rare
occasion lose my cool that I'm not
myself and Marian she soon joins me as
Snickers that is a fact that is a true
story DeMarcus I'm not just saying that
cuz if for your sponsoring today every
now and then you know but just so we're
like last year was the Snickers this
year for me I'm just a happier guy you
know what I'm so I'm gonna make sure I
send some pictures of this chain so you
might do it I want to get hungry again
this is B bring it to me before I let
you go your Super Bowl 50 for prediction
is what DeMarcus Ware I would say the
Kansas City Chiefs and the grounds okay
okay I would say I feel like the Rams
are there they're really hungry about
last year about what happened and they
feel like they were snow then they wanna
really come out with a lot of firepower
and the Kansas City
Chiefs I think they're gonna finally now
with my home saying I got I know what
was expected I know what's under my bill
now I can go out and do it I was young
last year now I'm the head honcho
DeMarcus Ware you are you're the best
man thanks for the call appreciate that
the insight about Gerry Jones's votive
candle by the way great fantasy team
name for next year
Jerry Jones's votive candles fantastic
good to chat with you Dee where that's
DeMarcus Ware courtesy of Snickers right
here in the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app